Most of what we call the Muslim world,
which again, North Africa, the Middle
East, but all into Asia, okay, and in
sub-Saharan Africa, the vast majority of
that land was taken by conquest. So, I
mentioned what was taken from
Christians. Iran was the Zoroastrian
great civilization that was conquered.
Um
Pakistan, okay, which land of the pure,
well, those are just Hindus who finally
were conquered and converted to Islam,
okay? Even in Indonesia, there's this
sort of story about, "No, no, it didn't
spread through violence." But there was
actually a lot of coercion once Muslims
grew in numbers.
Um so, so that's the warning. So, now
you fast forward to today, and your
average Westerner European has no idea
about this. You know, all what they know
is colonialism and you know, evil
Europeans. And now we're going to make
it up for them. I mean, that's the logic
in the UK, for example. That's why it's
flooded with Pakistanis because uh we're
making up for our sins in colonizing
their lands, and we're bringing them
here. That kind of logic. And to you,
that's patently ridiculous. It's
patently ridiculous because, okay, uh
you have to understand what you who and
what you're bringing in. And the lot
Okay, so now you brought in, let's say
the UK and the really big ones, UK,
Germany, and France. But also Sweden, um
you know, and the numbers of Muslims are
growing in Italy, Spain just gave a
blanket acceptance of like a million
migrants, which is kind of insane.
Spain went through 800 years of war to
evict Muslims, okay? The Reconquista,
literally.
Because they couldn't get along. And now
they're bringing him. So, it just shows
you the massive disconnect between
the Western world with with its history,
and the Muslim world, like I said, is
continuity. So, okay, when Muslims come
to Europe, so just to explain to you
some ideas.
According to Islamic rule, Islamic law,
Sharia, Muslims are forbidden from
voluntarily migrating to live under
non-Muslim rule, infidel rule. You have
to live in the lands of Sharia, where
Islam is Islam is uh
dominates, okay? Why would you go live
with the enemy? Because the non-Muslim
>> That Oh, yeah, that's stated. Okay.
>> Okay. But now, there's caveats, okay,
which I'll get to. So, that I mean, but
that is the normal state of affairs.
They're the enemy.
We're the Muslims. The Quran is full of
this whole doctrine, which um it's in
Arabic it's called al-wala' wal-bara',
which means Muslims must only help,
befriend, like, side with, and be loyal
to Muslims of the ummah.
Well, ummah basically means the suprana-
national uh Islamic community that
transcends race, you know, language,
ethnicity,
and geography.
And they must have hatred for the
non-Muslim. And when and whenever they
can, they must wage war and try to
subjugate them. Okay? That is a a legit
doctrine straight out of the Quran. I've
written a lot about it. I can give you
some verses if you want.
But so, that's the driving doctrine that
propelled the historic jihad. It still
exists. Muslims still think this way.
So, then you bring masses of them into
Europe. I mentioned the main countries,
uh England and UK and whatnot.
And if you look there, you got there's a
lot of problems, okay? I mean, nobody's
going to argue that, if you want to be
honest. Of course, there are certain
people want to put their head in the
sand and say, "No, no, everything's
fine." But no, there's massive problems.
You probably heard of this Restore
Britain new party that came out. I mean,
there's a reason why people and if you
hear the words of what he's saying, uh I
think his last name is Low, um you know,
it's it's on the one hand, it's
refreshing because it's basically what
everyone there's thinking.
You know, on the other hand, it's like I
can't you you you never would have
imagined someone talking that way a
decade ago. But why is he? Because it's
a reflection
>> a flag for people. So, some people that
are watching this right now, their base
assumption is going to be
uh Rupert Lowe is a wild bigot. Uh you
are giving this cuz you've got some axe
to grind around bigotry and we'll get to
growing up as an Egyptian Christian and
what that means and all of that. Um but
I want to so I wanted to get all of that
out on the table so that people
understand what the sort of core thesis
is, what you're worried about, that
there's all this historical continuity.
Um Muslims are driven by a core
doctrine. That core doctrine says that
you should be going in and conquering um
based on the religious doctrine. We've
got people now going into these
countries
uh call it immigration through conquest.
You didn't say that but I know your work
I'm familiar enough that I know that
that's a a thing on the table. Okay. Now
I want to back up and I want to walk
through what the foundational beliefs
are that you have that leads you to that
because I want the people watching this
to be able to draw a well-informed
conclusion as to whether this is just
bigotry or whether there really is a
reason to be concerned about this. Um so
how did you grow up? Your parents are
>> [clears throat]
>> uh immigrants from Egypt uh but they're
not Muslim. So give me that background,
what that was like and most importantly
how it informs your views. Okay.
So my um correct, I was born here. My
parents immigrated from Egypt. Um
they're what's called Coptic Christians,
okay? And the word Coptic is uh
basically a corruption of the Greek word
Aigyptos, which is where we get our
English Egyptian. It's Aigyptos. And so
when the Arabs invaded and they met the
Aigyptos, they just called them Gypt.
They dropped the first and last
syllables and Gypt eventually found its
way to us as Copt, okay? So
but now it means, you know, the
indigenous inhabitants of Egypt
pre-Islam who still exist in minorities
and are Christians because like I was
telling you, those countries were still
Christian when the when the Arabs
invaded them. Egypt was conquered around
641 AD.
Okay, so
Now, here's the thing and I know where
you're going with this cuz people have
said this to me before which is oh you
you it's because you're a Christian and
you feel like Muslims took over your
country and you have an axe to grind.
And I've heard that before. Now, here
here's the the the truth that most
people don't understand and if you find
an Egyptian or a Copt from Egypt, most
of them are going to tell you yeah.
Which is actually a lot of Coptic
Christians don't even like what I'm
saying. And will not agree with me. And
they and they like their they will tell
you all my friends are all Muslims.
You're a hate-monger. What what are you
doing? And I would actually argue my
parents would have been at least
neutral. Yeah, they weren't like we love
Muslims but they wouldn't have said, you
know, oh yeah, Muslims are all monsters
or evil. So, I I I can honestly say that
that the only thing that my own personal
background made of might have done is it
drew interest in the question in the
first place. My main interest is
history. I studied history. That's what
I majored in in history. And so it was
natural of course for me to gravitate to
those topics that are part of who I am.
Okay, so yeah, okay, I'm a Copt. I'm
Christian. Muslims but it's so that's
why my first thesis was for example
about the first military conflict
between Muslims and Christians cuz I was
involved in military history at the
time.
So, I don't think that you know, my my
if anything my background if you really
dig into it and you know, there's this
theory that oh yeah, every Christian
from the Islamic world hates Muslims and
they're being persecuted and that's not
even true. I mean
that's one of the topics I'm expert in.
I have a another book on the persecution
of Christians. And we can talk about
that but um most Christians would
actually because it's a cultural thing.
A lot of Christians from the Middle East
are culturally like Muslims. So, if you
put a if you put an American Christian
and a Coptic Christian and an Egyptian
Muslim, the Coptic Christian and the
Muslim are going to be best friends.
Mhm. Because culturally they see things
eye to eye.
So, I tell you all this, okay, so you
understand that no, that's not in any
way
Christians are not born and bred with
this all those Muslims we can't wait
till we get away from them. Okay, now
obviously there's some who did
experience persecution in the modern era
and it's getting worse now, but like
let's say in my parents' day it wasn't
that bad at all. You know, the the
Muslims were were were this is let's say
my parents were born in the 40s.
You know, so they're growing up in the
60s. It Muslims in Egypt at that time
were nowhere near as radical as today.
And even today a lot of them are not
radical.
So
again, I'm just telling you all this
that just to tell you that that is if
anything that should have moderated my
views. If we know that Muslims and
Christians can live side by side and not
end up having animosity towards each
other. Um
how is that consistent with your view
that there's this pattern that repeats
through history and so it's just sort of
inevitable and if you're not careful
it's going to happen again. Cuz that
tells me at least for one period
everybody was fine living together. My
ultimate point is the religion of Islam
as it is as it is understood, written
down, documented, black and white in the
Quran, codified by the ulama or the
clerics, okay?
Is is an intolerant and violent creed
that is incompatible with the West.
That's my message, okay?
Now what happens
>> [laughter]
>> inevitably and we're having it right now
and I'm glad we are because it's
important is all of a sudden now we
conflict the religion with the people.
Okay? And with every religion,
Christianity, Judaism, whatever, you
have teachings and then you have people
who are to varying degrees associated
with the teaching, okay?
Uh we can look at let's just look at
okay, look at Judaism, right? You have
the actual
Orthodox Jews and then you have I think
they're called the the reformed or or um
liberal Jews, okay?
Okay, but they're all Jews, right? And
even the I think they're called reformed
Jews
who are like liberal Jews are you know,
they'll tell you well, I'm I believe
this, but the Orthodox believe something
else. Okay, so
but as it happens, the Orthodox, I'm
sure, are much closer to Judaism. And as
it happens, the radicals
>> As written, you mean?
>> As written, yeah. They're being more
consistent They're being more loyal or
adherent to the actual text and the
traditions and the history.
Now, the same thing with Islam. So, as I
described to you Islam, it is what it
is. It's violent, it's intolerant, it's
not out to live in coexistence. It's
just out supreme, all right? Now, the
Muslims within Islam, you know, what are
there almost 2 billion people?
You're going to have some who think
that's great and who love it and who
want to activate it and who want to be
part of it. You're going to find some
who don't even know about it, who don't
care, just like the many nominal
Christians in the West who say I'm a
Christian, but what do they even know
about Christianity, right? You So,
you're going to have Muslims like that.
You're going to have Muslims who even
know what's what's that there's bad
stuff, but they're not going to They're
not going to live with it. They're going
to No, there's going to be Muslims who
know the bad stuff and they agree to it,
but they're not going to commit to it.
>> [snorts]
>> Not yet because it's the
the situation's not opportune.
So, I guess my point is I have I've
going back to my background and all
that. I've I've objectively studied
Islam. I know the I know the the
languages, the original languages. It's
been my academic background. I've
written books.
And what I'm telling you is not coming
from I'm a bitter
cop with an axe to grind. It's coming If
anything, that should have tempered me.
Most of the cops I know actually don't
like what I'm doing. You know, you're
being a troublemaker. People live in
peace. Okay. So, to go back to that,
well, are they living in peace or not?
Well, it Who's doing what? Some
Christians in Egypt and in Middle
Eastern countries get a persecuted. Some
get killed. Some have Muslim neighbors
who they get along with.
Bring [music]
back the
Bring back the fire.
>> [music]
>> flame. back the
fire
and the
righteous name.